two Americans dead at the hands of a
brutal Mexican cartel the victims were
on a trip with two other friends when
they were violently kidnapped after
crossing the border video shows the
moment when they were abducted and
tossed into the back of a truck the
Americans were in Mexico to get a
medical procedure and reportedly got
lost looking for the clinic that's when
they got caught in the crosshairs of a
cartel shootout authorities think they
were mistaken for a rival gang Mexico
says one suspect has been arrested so
far and they are still looking for
others responsible
the two Americans who survived are
finally back in the U.S being treated at
a Texas hospital Republicans say this is
a Tipping Point and it's time to take
down the cartels
I'm going to introduce legislation Jesse
to make certain Mexican drug cartels
foreign terrorist organizations under
U.S law and set the stage to use
military force if necessary to protect
America from being poisoned by things
coming out of Mexico they are terrorists
I think there's another hostage and
that's the Mexican Government The
Mexican government is being held hostage
by tens of thousands of paramilitary
members of terrorist organizations that
effectively control Mexico and Peter
Ducey pressing the White House on the
cartel killings
cartels kill Americans on this side of
the border with drugs and now they're
killing Americans on the other side of
the border with guns why is President
Biden so comfortable with cartel's
operating so close to the U.S because of
the work that this president has done
because of what we've done specifically
on fentanyl at the border it's at
historic lows what garbage anyway that
made no sense
um this is kind of a crazy story Dana
but it's also in a way not surprising
because you never know what you're going
to get into when you cross the board
right there are so the state department
puts out uh notices saying these are
places you should not travel to and that
doesn't mean you can't travel there and
it doesn't mean that you should be
assaulted while you are there there are
some things that we still need to
understand were they specifically
targeted as soon as they came through
the checkpoint
um that I'm not sure about Eric Erickson
tweeted today that he had counted it up
more than 600 Americans were abducted by
drug cartels in 2021 in Mexico and those
are usually treated like a local news
story now
to his point imagine that we're Isis or
Al Qaeda and 600 Americans were
kidnapped that would be a very different
story and we and maybe that does need to
change and Jim Jordan tweeted something
I thought was interesting he said that
you had not just only the cartels
kidnapping and killing Americans this
week a female border patrol agent was
violently assaulted by an illegal
Crosser when she was trying to deal with
him uh fentanyl smuggled across daily
I'm not exactly sure what the press
secretary was meaning that there is
historic lows I I don't think that that
is true look at the moms and dads that
are dealing with all of this and then
the question is at this point you have
people on Capitol Hill saying we need to
do something about the drug cartels
there's this graphic that we did on
America's Newsroom at Bill's you know
billboard and it showed on a graph how
many cartels are in America it has like
the five different colors it was
shocking all across the country they
have a presence here and so this isn't
something that we have sought out oh we
have a right look at that look at our
producers putting it right up that is
shocking to me that's how many cartels
are right here in America so it's one
thing to say you should deal with the
cartels over there we also have to deal
with them here it is incredible I was
pretty ignorant of their influence Jesse
until I had that conversation with you
and we're talking about your buddy who
said basically cartels have muscled out
all the other gangs but yeah there's no
other gangs these guys are running the
crime in Chicago and it's just like it
blows my mind that you can actually
enter a country illegally and all and I
mean talk about the land of opportunity
right rise to the top you you're the top
of the food chain illegally it's true
well it's because we love cocaine so
much if we stop speak for yourself that
was talking about Geraldo okay if we
stop doing so much cocaine we just take
away all the demand and that's the
problem but no one's going to stop doing
cocaine so we have to figure out a new
solution so you have to play these guys
off of each other there's three big ones
you got golf Sinaloa and Jalisco Bay and
it looks like Sinaloa is the top dog so
you either have to cut a deal with
Sinaloa to put down golf in Jalisco Bay
or you have to work each other off of
them with the Mexican Government the
Mexican Government tried to to cut a
deal with one of them but then the other
two got bigger so this was golf that
controls this area and they've
disintegrated but if you're going to
start throwing missiles at these guys
that's a possibility that's what Senator
Lindsey Graham wants to do and there's a
house resolution also saying the same
thing let's say you lob a missile into
one of these things how do they respond
I mean you saw the imprint they have in
the United States proper what if they
just blow up an apartment complex in
Phoenix and then you're dealing with
some sort of terrorism on U.S soil uh
that's a whole different ball game so
but they're already killing a hundred
thousand exactly so you have to do this
strategically it's also going to cause a
huge trade problem because the Mexican
president's not going to like being
emasculated when we start throwing
missiles into his territory and their
biggest trading partner so that's going
to dry up autos and jets so it has to be
done strategically does Joe Biden have a
plan absolutely not and for the binder
to pretend like this is a big success
because we're seizing more fentanyl
that's the dumbest argument I've ever
heard she's saying we're having success
stopping illegal aliens because we're
there's more encounters than ever before
so this woman needs to get her brain
checked Biden needs to have a strategy
because I don't like the idea of
Americans being kidnapped and
slaughtered by a cartel a mile across
the border that's that's not neighborly
and we have to do something and it has
to be military well I mean okay so
Geraldo uh Lindsey grandma said this
Trump has said it I think uh Vivek
ramaswamy Jesse militarily going in and
what Precision assassinations it would
be an absolute disaster first of all for
the record I was never into cocaine
unlike some at this table which whose
names I've gotten yeah Dana
put it down Snow White never got caught
in 2019 remember the Mormon family nine
of them including little babies
slaughtered and the Mexican side of the
Border during the Trump Administration
the United States did not take military
action you can't take military action
it's not the days of the important not
about this family but about the hundred
thousand that are dying from fentanyl
for it's a horrible horrible situation
but you have to have the Mexican
Government working with you I think the
way to thrust them the way that you can
you cannot you cannot I agree with you
Garcia Luna the guy who is the J Edgar
Hoover of Mexico the head of the
judicial branch of the government uh you
know went down a light facing life
imprisonment uh El Chapo's cartel
dealing uh dealing drugs getting huge
payoffs but you've got to get the Mexi
if you attack Mexico The Mexican
government or the Mexican people will
rise up against you the better idea I
think is to use trade squeeze As Trump
at times did he used it effectively in
terms of immigration but I think you've
really got to make it clear to the
Mexican people that it is in their
vested interest to do the best they can
to to provide information to honest cops
but military has to be on the table
Geraldo the U.S military yes put it on
the table the history of imperialism in
Latin America runs very deep and to use
the military against a Latin American
country would be virtually impossible I
did it in Colombia it would be like
the Colombian consent in a civil war
that had divided the country I was there
I was in Colombia with U.S forces in the
Colombian jungle and still not doing
cooking I never okay I don't never but I
mean virtually never virtually
you know it's almost like it's not
really an either or thing I mean what
we're talking about is trying to make
the cost of doing business nearly
impossible so that is like there's no
risk for them to do this we need to
create a risk and the only way you can
do that is threat of death
I agree yeah okay who are you gonna kill
we know where everybody is okay
this is what I think number one you've
got one of the most dangerous one of the
oldest drug cartels involved here they
thought it was another opposing drug
gang that's why there was a shootout
okay and number two the corruption in
Mexico is staggering it is at every
level of government it's even
generational where the grandfather took
money the sun's taking money the
grandson and then what you have is this
concept of oh great let's just do some
military strikes if we do a military
strike the problem is we're going to
inevitably hit someone in the government
because they are working with the
cartels okay that puts us at another
level and it's a never-ending War
because the United States is the
marketplace we are the people who want
the cocaine all right and so it is it's
never ending I don't know what to do
legalization it could be legalization it
could be but if you look at that if you
look at that uh map of where the cartels
are in America that is that is a killer
that is that is to me that's treason to
allow that to exist in this country is
treason and if you go three miles over
the border from Brownsville Texas and
you get yourself shot up I mean then you
know you have to talk to Americans short
order number one you don't go to a level
four area number two if you do go as an
American to Mexico you take someone
who's been in the military who knows how
to protect you and number three we've
got to do something at this end about
the the drug problem that we have
yeah amen all right I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now